a balancing act addressing macroeconomic
imbalances Europe's economies are very
closely linked we trade freely with each
other and many of us even share the same
currency this means that we depend on
each other for our success and that we
all need to maintain our balance but
when one of our economies wobbles others
may be affected too for instance high
unemployment all persistently low
investment in one country could affect
other countries by lowering the demand
for their goods similarly if a country's
competitiveness deteriorates and it
imports much more than it exports it
will develop a trade deficit or need to
be financed by foreign investors this
could leave the country vulnerable to
market shifts market bubbles are a good
example of what can happen when an
economy gets out of balance fast rising
house prices in some countries in recent
years made investors overly optimistic
and overstretched when the bubbles got
out of hand crisis came crashing down
leaving home owners banks and taxpayers
to pick up the pieces to help EU
countries to stay in balance the
European Commission has put in place an
annual exercise to detect and address
risky wobbles before they cause injuries
while monitoring the correction of
existing imbalances because a healthy
economy is a balanced economy
the European economy stronger together